well we're talking about accidental
pregnancy i'm not talking about
like the guy the choice between a guy
beating you and like
talking about the beat yeah but even
even the
actual having the child obviously it's
come from
um non-protected sex right so my point
is
i could have been protected and as well
it's like does that not show you how men
can be coercively abusive in the sense
of how many men have said how many men
have said let me just put a tip in
and they keep going but where are you
and how many women have said okay like
why are you telling me
what's happening like no i mean i'm
saying like that was a choice like you
don't have to deal with those guys
so the
i'm saying like that's a choice you
don't have to deal with those guys like
so so that that's a personal choice
and another thing as well you see you
just you just said it there you're still
in control that
understanding of circumstance you're in
control if he sees the children or not
if it was the other way around this is
why we this conversation we're having
today if you was like that
you're still in control
so we don't have the control i have in
our own children when we want to see
them yeah but he also has control no one
has control in the sense of if you want
to see your children you go to the court
no but if he doesn't but you don't have
to stop looking into the mic sorry but
this is my point right there and like
you see because i know your circumstance
and what he's done i don't know so i can
only believe what you don't actually
know you know what she told you yeah
exactly that's what i can only believe
what you're saying
no no you don't even have to because i'm
just saying
based on what you're saying you're
saying he can go all of that is a
process i've had to wait months to go to
cool and all that mental and time
it affects your psyche and depending on
what kind of person it is so it's like
all you got to do is that's a lot in
itself those children are still sitting
at home with you
no but again
so many options it wasn't just the
process no no no i heard you clearly i'm
saying i get what you're saying you're
not one of them ladies trying to not let
him sing he's been abused i heard that
but what i'm saying is that what we
everyone's disc what the discussion is
is that you see because it's on the
man's side of things
this is not discussed about misanji and
our parental alienation are women
because always see the men away the
deadbeats if the women sit around in the
room to if he don't do this he don't pay
women will be like yeah yeah jonah said
no generally speaking because it's not a
woman so what i'm saying it's until when
a man come and speaks about it so oh
he's actually doing more than just being
a weekend father do you know what i mean
so that's not what it is i rate the men
that are like that so much because at
least you're fighting for your child but
not every man come here
not every man wants to fight the fight
women have to fight for their children
but at the end of the day for your child
you will fight i'm fighting for my
children
i'm protecting them no but they mean i
get you you protect them in the home but
you're not fighting
against someone taking them from you
you're you're as a mother instinctively
you love you and and cherish your
children and nurture them technically i
am because he's threatened to and he has
tried to okay yeah but
i'm just saying you keep making it so
personal we're trying to talk general
like
like we're not saying that your
situations don't exist we're just saying
that you know generally yeah when men
are fighting for their children they
have a certain threshold when men are
fighting for something that they love
they have a certain threshold even if
it's with a woman after fighting for a
woman for solomon black you know what
forget about it i'm not doing it right
so it's the same with children it's not
the fact that they don't want to see
their children it's a fact that they're
in a situation where they're not willing
to fight anymore and when it comes to
that
women need to understand that every man
has their limit so if you push the man
to the limit and then he says well you
know what don't worry about it then
she'll go around saying oh he's a dead
beat dad it's like no hang on he wasn't
actually a deadbeat dad he actually
wanted to fight for his children you i'm
not talking about you but you as a woman
made it so hard for him to see his child
that he said you know what
keep him you know i can agree with that
because there are some women where say
for example their children are taken
away because they have neglected them or
they've abused them or whatever it is
and they have the option to do the right
thing to get the children back they
don't fight they go out they go out
raven they go out smoking drinking
whatever it is and they don't do enough
to get their children back so i do get
what you're saying and even in that are
they fit enough to have their children
in the first place if that's the case so
we have to look at sorry
no no that's okay no no you're fine
you know when you look at relationships
and children speaking to them oh sorry
looking at the partnership in itself the
foundation that partnership is built on
if you look at most of these
relationships you realize that the
foundation was dodgy from the jump
and i think it's about mutual respect
when there's no mutual respect between
two individuals then there can never be
a solid partnership regardless of
children
a breakup whatever there's always
someone who's lacking from quite early
on you get what i'm saying yeah and it's
funny you said that because that's what
i'm saying about you saying about the
protecting how many mothers or how many
women you know that know that other
women abusive towards their children
like you don't hear much women i don't
hear it come out and talk about
women
knowing that other women views their
children and they will they'll be the
first to talk about abuse and
psychological abuse and all this in my
circumstances where i can talk honestly
and know clearly about it that women
won't come forward
about other women abuse in fact when you
even saw social look how much it takes
for them to remove a child
why they wouldn't do that they do it
anonymously yeah but why they wouldn't
do that because then they would hold
them have to hold themselves accountable
for what they do because then they're in
acknowledging behaviors that they commit
to themselves so are we talking about
the other friends that so if a woman is
abusing a child and another woman knows
about it and she's co-signing or
whatever
she has to acknowledge the part she
plays in allowing it to happen
or if she does it herself say like
they're agreeing they're both single
mothers they're slating the father or
whatever they she would have to
acknowledge her part in playing that
behavior herself yeah so they join
allegiance to not even join allegiance
on both sides of the field i'm trying to
be fair here
it's about taking accountability for
your part to play in the problem
everybody can everybody can point the
finger kind of point out the problem but
what is the solution
i've already said many times women only
women don't like other women generally
but the only time they do is when it's
time to go against men
when it's time to go against men you'll
get a bunch of them be like yeah men are
this blah blah but you take men of that
equation and then women are looking at
each other as competition they're
looking at your hair they're looking at
your nails they're looking at your shoes
they're looking at this and they're
looking at you as competition
that's that's i thought we were
oh
still boils down to accountability
because when you look at say for example
i could acknowledge every woman in this
room is beautiful now if there's a man
that i like and i can see there's other
women that could potentially take him
from me in my eyes
it's natural to feel like boom like how
do i bolster myself up in that way do
you get what i mean so
no no i think every woman is different
it's not it's a natural response because
you like somebody or they they're your
partner maybe you feel like oh you know
the way my man is interacting with these
women it's a threat to me do you
understand what i'm saying so a lot of
women won't acknowledge that there's
other women in the room that are better
than them they i can be in a room and i
can acknowledge there's women that have
qualities that i don't have and when you
acknowledge that you have confidence in
yourself
and that's what that normally makes
other women jealous and like yeah
say for example like what you're saying
a man in the room will say it's my man
and nobody might know that he's not my
man because i won't necessarily show it
i'm not that type of girl me i'm just me
and i'm just there and that's that yeah
but let's just say like the guy was in
the room and other women are pushing up
on him
yeah it's intense it can be what you're
doing no but it's interesting no no no
but it's internalized you don't have to
project it outwardly you feel it and as
a woman if you like a man or you're with
a man and you don't feel
protective over your man that's a bit of
i think there's a level guys hang on one
second